[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
corporate chess league 2022 spring
season i think this is week number three
for us here in the season and we've got
pretty exciting matchups lined up for
you it's gonna be pretty much the same
as it has been the first two times if
you if this is the first time you're
joining us the corporate chess league is
a fantastic league in the st louis area
for st louis corporations to compete
against each other duke it out on the
chessboard see which corporation has the
best chess players in their ranks and
how do they determine that well we have
a regular season grand prix where teams
compete for grand prix points those
teams that finish with the most grand
prix points will qualify for a playoff
and in the playoffs they battle until a
single winner is determined and that
winner gets their glory permanently
engraved into the corporate chess league
chessboard
what teams do we have tonight what we've
got enterprise and edward jones our top
two teams uh from week to week more or
less they are facing off against tardy
and ascension another two uh teams that
have been in the corporate chess league
for some time now battling over the
chessboard doing their best to prove
their worth
um how does this actually work well each
of these teams uh will play against each
other in a two-game match so they have
different boards of players each board
plays two games one with the white
pieces one with the black pieces
and the at the end of the match each
board's points are counted up for their
team and the winner of the match is
whoever scores more points and then that
gets them 20 grand pre-points for a
match victory if the match ends in a tie
each team would get 10 grand pre-points
and then in addition to that each
individual boards points are counted
towards the grand prix so for example if
a team wins eight to four in a match
they get 20 points for winning the match
plus those eight points that they scored
within the match the time control for
these games is going to be game in 10
minute i believe with zero second
increment that means we're going to see
a lot of games ending on the clock you
have to move fast in the corporate chess
league otherwise you're going to get
left behind
and just go through some of the players
here it looks like we've got a lot of
the usual suspects but edward jones
missing some of their top boards that uh
that i've seen from week to week as is
enterprise so that's gonna be a big
chance for dardy and ascension to maybe
take some points off of these two two
favorites
of course alex kurford the league
commissioner and one of the top players
for edward jones i'm not seeing him on
this list of course edward jones also
lost their killer board one vishal
bharadwaj
although he is not competing for any of
the other teams he did end up leaving
the company so edward jones may be
suffering here here tonight it'll be
interesting to see uh if the the strong
ascension and doherty teams are going to
be able to pick up some coveted grand
prix points
in round one of course though we have
enterprise facing doherty that's going
to look like kendalum on board one for
enterprise against desrat
board 2 is going to be moneyballin for
enterprise up against i love legos 2 who
still has one of my favorite names in
the corporate chess league uh speaking
of some of my favorite names big daddy
jazz 64 for enterprise on board three up
against mike schimwick for board three
on dardy
now i know darty has not had the most
impressive performances historically but
uh i know that actually the ceo of dardy
is a big chess player and so i'm sure
he's encouraging this team to try their
best to train up and i i think we can
expect them to continue improving as we
go
uh edward jones their board one this
week is going to be fishers of men their
board 2 paul frowen board 3 debo274 who
i think might be a new addition to the
edward jones team haven't seen them
before
and board four is going to be miquez who
i think has cleaned up historically on
board for been a very strong board for
for edward jones
all the usual suspects are there for
ascension in frank t tan maurice gp s
gilmore 999 and oak ave oak ave also a
very strong board for from what i
remember
um without any further ado i think games
should be getting underway momentarily
we've got some players i think still
trying to get connected here but most
everybody is is joining us so i want to
say thank you to everybody out there
we're live on youtube and twitch thanks
for joining us hopefully it's going to
be an exciting night for you guys here i
see orlando in the chat along with rohit
uh hello to both of you thanks for
joining thanks for joining
and i think we we have liftoff uh looks
like the first game is between two
players that i did not mention so we
have an extra match or two going on so
sometimes there's not always an even
number of players and we have extra
matches and that's going to take place
here between nmc gin who i think is
playing for enterprise and mega cake who
i believe is just a house player for us
so tough first matchup
and
looks like mega cake taking their time
finding their first move hello to manny
lp in the twitch chat
and i'm not totally sure what the hold
up is but we'll give everybody a moment
here to get connected let me see if i
can refresh see if we've got anybody
else
joining
it looks like just about everybody's
online they just need to uh
to start the games up
so once again this is week three i
believe in the first two weeks both
enterprise and edward jones had a pretty
strong showing
again they do tend to be the favorites
in these matches
but uh this week again both players or
both teams seem to be missing a lot of
their top players no john boyer for
enterprise who has been an excellent
team captain for them i think he's
actually been organizing their team
trying to get them to do these training
sessions uh trying to work with us to
see if we can get the uh
our resident grand master to do some
instruction for them um so i know that
they've been training super hard but
john noticeably absent here tonight he's
normally one of the strongest players in
the corporate chess league
and again for edward jones missing
vishal on board one
and if i'm thinking back i think they
had a different board one um last week
as well so missing some of their
strongest players missing alex kurford
um
so definitely doherty and ascension
gonna be looking to to take their points
today
are the legs separate or is it
consecutive so we are doing this pretty
much every other week and we are in the
midst of the regular season right now so
all these teams are competing in a grand
prix as i kind of mentioned at the top
so if they do well tonight they'll score
grand prix points for their teams and
then the top teams qualify for a playoff
uh for the playoffs based on however
many points they score during the
regular season
uh hello to john b in the youtube chat
that wouldn't be jon boy or would it
would it be john john where are you
tonight your team is missing you
um in the meantime we do actually have
liftoff only in one game but it's
something to talk about rather than just
me waffling on here so we've got nmc gin
uh playing again in the extra matches so
this game not part of the main matches
but he will still be scoring board
points for enterprise
and he's got to do it against make a
cake though uh pretty strong player it
looks like and off to
not such a great start for nmc gin uh
blundering that the e4 pawn looks like
he was trying to play some kind of
vienna game here
mega kick responds with a quick d5 and
this is normally what you want to be
doing against early f4s and that kind of
thing from white in e4 e5 openings in
general whenever white's playing some
kind of crazy gambit looking thing
oftentimes black can just play d5 fight
back in the center and get a pretty open
game
white play d3 which i don't think is
going to be the best response because
here after knight takes
the e4 pawn
just gets left behind
and with this white does not try to take
back on e5 to regain the pawn
it just goes for quick development but
this is going to be a very good position
now for black black's up up an extra
pawn not too far behind in development
there's natural moves like bishop d6
here to complete development get the
king castled queens are off the board
and i think black should just be pretty
significantly better
pretty significantly better here we'll
see what mega cake comes up with though
yeah just play c6 and i really don't
like this move you just want to you want
to finish your development in positions
like these you know you're already up a
pawn you don't want to mess around uh
waste your time before you get fully
developed because that's how white
starts to get some some compensation
so now for example bishop d3 very
natural move for white develops with
tempo i love it from nmc gin
off to a bad start but he's recovering
now he's got three pieces developed to
blacks one
okay knight c5 is a good tempo move in
reply
if i'm white here yeah i'm thinking i
don't have time to move this bishop i
want to get rapid development quickly
quickly quickly um and yeah black does
not even take the time
to to capture that bishop
now if i'm white you can really think
about castling in either direction
c4 is really not going to be it though
c4 is is not the way
maybe he was thinking he wants to castle
queenside he was worried about leaving
this a2 pawn behind but
immediately i think it would really be
okay to castle because if if the bishop
takes i'm sure you've all seen this
bishop trap before with b3
and i think white can really get away
with doing this here normally you should
be worried about some sacrifices but
queens are off the board i think you are
just going to trap that bishop and go up
a piece with c4 now yeah you are just
going to blunder the c4 pawn to this
tactic and then actually wow knight c5
and and the the day the day is getting
worse for nmc gin uh john busy with some
family stuff but he still showed up to
cheer on his team
which hopefully they can get underway
soon
um
if i'm not mistaken this is still the
only game we've got going on so
hopefully there's not too many technical
difficulties going on
let me try
doing something like this
and yeah uh not sure what's going on
looks like the players are having some
some uh difficulties getting started
but uh we'll stick with the one game
that we've got going on
so black does get castled and it's just
a piece to the good here uh white's
gonna try and make something happen
but shouldn't be too big of a deal for
uh
for make a cake here
so yeah as uh ben in the chat pointed
out
each
match consists of two games between each
player one with the white pieces one
with black pieces
and
that totals four games total for the
night there's two rounds of two games
each in the night
where you can get a st louis chess club
cup or mug so at the st louis chess club
i think we do sell these and you are
also welcome to check out the q boutique
online they have
a lot of our chess gear they are more so
with the chess hall of fame than us but
we do have some stuff on there
you're new to chess do you have any tips
well
i'm sure i will have many many tips as
the night goes on here the game we're
looking at right now
not quite as interesting as it was in
the beginning
but uh
but still still some intrigue to be had
here in general just when you're new to
chess the best way to get better is to
keep playing keep working on it and
start to get more and more familiar with
how those pieces are moving how squares
are attacked things like that that's the
thing you want to do
do we ship to europe i have no idea but
i'm sure that
we have we believe so
more info on that website
okay knight to a6 so this is an attempt
by black to connect the rooks if i'm
white here i'm thinking about how i can
invade i think maybe this move knight d7
is gonna be required you really need to
get the rooks active you need to get
into the seventh rank here to have any
chance
um now i don't think it's going to make
a difference in this game but it would
be at least a a good attempt
knight d3 instead is kind of just the
wrong direction
now with black i think we're going to
even put a rook onto the d file and
trade off one of these guys so if knight
c5 will take on d2 take back then we can
take this bishop or this knight rather
maintain our extra piece and start to
simplify things a little bit when you're
ahead in material like this you really
just want to get pieces off the board
get things to be a little bit more
simple so there's less room for you to
uh you know blunder make mistakes and
let your opponent back into the game
that being said really anything is going
to be fine here for black i also
wouldn't mind the move bishop b6 because
it helps control the d8 square which
allows black again
to contest this open file that's really
the last big problem for black to solve
here you want to get your rooks on this
file
uh make sure that white cans can't
invade anywhere and cause you problems
black chose bishop e7 which does largely
the same thing you just want to defend
this square so that your rooks can can
come come into the game
how's it going spinal tap good to see
you
welcome to the corporate chess league
that we've got going on here
and again the time is ticking on i don't
think i'm missing anything here i think
the games just have not gotten started
not sure
exactly what's going on but hopefully
they can get that figured out maybe ben
can see if he can find any of the games
but
yeah from what i can tell
no one is playing chess aside from nmc
gin
yeah it looks like some sort of
difficulty
uh for these teams getting started but
hopefully we can get underway before too
long here
in the meantime megacake
is doing exactly what i was recommending
just getting on this file he's up a
piece he's up a couple pawns you just
want to simplify contest this file make
sure white can't uh
get any tricks
so yeah 95 i see no reason not to trade
just want to get these ricks off the
board simplify
simplify the position a little bit and
make your life as easy as possible
there are many ways to win a chess game
but there's really not that many ways to
do it without risk even when you're
super winning like this
uh you want to find ways to just
eliminate risk make sure there's no way
you're ever going to blunder
and you can do that by you know trading
pieces doing simple things like making
left even if you don't think backrank
mate's going to be a problem um you just
want to make sure as easy as possible or
at least that's that's how i approach it
when i'm super winning
the other participants might just be
stunned
by the work of art by mega cake yeah i
tend to agree this has been a pretty
clean game
by by make cake so far
yeah knight f3 it's going to let black
get the the last rook off the board
and once these major pieces are off the
board look to see black number one
activate the king maybe f6 king f7 and
number two probably he wants to start
getting these pawns rolling that's how
the conversion usually goes here when
you're up a piece you can start to use
that extra piece to advance your pawns
since black is up three pawns to one
over here on the queen side that would
be a good area to try and make progress
here once you can push the pawns forward
you can try to make a queen once you
make a queen the rest is is sort of easy
the queen
is
very very strong very powerful
black chooses knight c5 i like this move
as well makes two different threats
white probably isn't able to keep all
the pieces on the board maybe you'll
even see them just trade okay king c2
instead a little curious now if bishop's
bishop f5 is going to be winning
bishop b3 is also playable looks looks a
little bit scary
white might might be running out of
squares for for the pieces here
deep sailor asks are there any good
teachers out there youtube does not help
at all well i'm a teacher on youtube uh
so maybe
uh either you might not think my
opinion's great or or you can check me
out i guess
um and yeah hello to io oyatola
says they're really enjoying this match
i'm glad
i'm glad
uh normally whenever these things are
going on i i leave the game when
someone's super winning but i guess it
can be useful to kind of see
the the full technique from start to
finish how you can turn
a peace advantage into a win again
without taking too many risks
um if i have one critique for make a
cake here it is the time usage it looks
like they're actually a little bit
um struggling with with the connection
uh looks like they're currently offline
so that might be might be why they're
taking some time here
but the time control is 10 plus oh so
very much uh flagging is going to be on
the table in a lot of these games so
they're going to have to look out for
that and make sure they're playing a
little bit faster to
avoid those kinds of problems
so king c2
and
we are down to one player connected
in the corporate chess league not always
ideal
all right i'm gonna refresh one more
time here
see if we got any other games going on
still nothing still just nothing no
one's responding to me
what on earth is going on
okay so black did end up connecting and
did go for this bishop f5 move that i
mentioned
um what was the point of that well uh we
wanted to force this king off to a worse
square
of course with knight c5 we were
threatening to fork the k in the rook so
after king c2 black says move your king
again and this time if you go to c3 i'll
have knight e4 if you go to c1 i'll have
knight p3 again so i think the only move
for white would have been king to d1
when maybe black could have tried
something like bishop g4 something
awkward like that to really force the uh
force the white king into a bad way
instead uh nmc jinn just goes knight or
king c3 but then of course after this
fork knight to e4 white is losing that
final rook uh black was going to be up a
full rook in that position
so white ended up resigning
um so there you go that's one way to win
a chess game
uh
who still says shouldn't black just
storm white from the queen's side yet
that's that's kind of what i recommended
to uh to win the game when you're up a
piece like that you really want to focus
on getting your pawns down the board so
you can make an extra queen and after
that the task gets a lot easier
but
make a cake just found a very concrete
way to simplify a little bit more get
some more pieces off which is also also
a great idea
so megacake gets the white pieces now
nmc gin again the only player in the
corporate chess league uh actually
playing a game so far
so
we'll stick with him we'll stick with
his battle against the the slightly
stronger mega cake and see how we can do
here
so pretty reasonable opening so far we
got nmc going for the super strong
triangle always love a good triangle
player
and
uh white's going for kind of kind of a
weird move order in my opinion let's
bishop back to h4 after this h6 move
and black can actually very seriously
consider taking on c4 in these positions
that's one advantage of the triangle is
after you take on c4 with this kind of
setup playing b5 afterwards is a very
serious consideration
um i think it's almost directly just the
note boom variation
which when i'm playing with the white
pieces i uh historically have kind of
struggled against the noteboom when
black just holds onto that pawn uh it
can be quite annoying and i've i've
struggled with it
oh instead
b5 directly uh i'm not sure about this
one this is a a sacrifice um by by nmc
here
and yes of course what i was referencing
is in this position if black were to
take on c4 white could play something
like e3 attacking the pawn with the
bishop and then black could play b5
holding onto that c4 pawn after e3 b5
directly white of course is just going
to take on this side of the board and
i'm not so sure i love this sacrifice by
black we're going to have to castle now
to step out of this knight c7 threat
and white's going to be a pawn to the
good
black and also consider throwing in a
check
ooh instead a6 but uh with this queen on
c2 knight to c7 check very much is on
the cards and that's that's gonna be a
bad miss it's gonna be a bad miss by by
nmc
so if i can say anything about this game
it would be a mistake that's um i notice
quite often uh with
you know players around the 1000 level
um players around a thousand to like
1300 i would say they've learned these
opening principles they know they're
supposed to develop their pieces and
castle their king
but then at some point they start to
think that uh they they know better and
they start to think well why should i
you know quote unquote waste a move
castling when i can do something more
active right away something active like
b5 or d takes c4 and then b5
uh and the answer is uh
you know you could do these things right
away
but
it's better to get your kings safe
before you do them because if you don't
and you go for these complications right
away you're going to find that you run
into things like knight to c7 check
being a problem you're going to run into
these sort of problems that you're going
to have to waste time later solving so
it's better to castle your king get
everything safe get everything ready
before you open up the position that way
you don't have to spend time after
things are open and crazy
to to solve those problems you know if
this king were already castled here then
you could play a move like a6 then you
could force this knight to to some
awkward squares
um but while your king's uncastled no
time to do this because knight c7 is
just gonna be winning the game
so that's that's my advice for this game
you want to
uh prepare everything before you you go
crazy and open up the position
and now we see rook to c1 and black
plays king to e7 to allow the rook to
defend the bishop but it's it's a little
bit too little too late uh best case
black is gonna be able to pick up this
knight somehow although i'm not really
convinced that we can even we can even
do that i think yeah there are some very
serious problems here
that's black is gonna have to solve like
you know you can play bishop b7 but
knight to c7 i think is
uh well on the way towards towards
escaping
bishop g3
uh if i'm white or if i'm black here i'm
probably looking at this move queen to
a5 i need some way to get some active
counter play
you want to uh
you want to get active here whenever
you're down material your only goal
should be to make things complicated
give your opponent chances to mess up
yeah bishop g3 is the opposite of that
whenever you trade pieces things get
simpler your opponent's task gets easier
the fewer pieces on the board gets
harder and harder for them to make that
critical mistake that lets you back into
the game
so i don't love bishop g3 something like
queen a5 check you want to get active
you want to get get aggressive when
you're down in material
deep sailor asks is it best to play
defensive or offensive at the start you
want my opinion
um it's sort of a sort of a weird
question um
you know i don't really think about
chess defensively or offensively um
you're always just looking to play the
best move in any position sometimes the
best move is defensive sometimes the
best move is offensive but you're just
looking for ways to improve your pieces
respond to threats make your own threats
and whether or not you need to play a
defensive move or an offensive move is
really just going to depend
on on the position sometimes your
opponent made a really strong threat and
you have to defend against it
sometimes your opponent didn't make a
strong threat and and you should do
something active
so i don't know if that helps at all um
but
uh maybe just change your style of
thinking you know don't focus on being
defensive or offensive just focus on the
specifics of the position
and and see what's the most important
okay knight back to c7 so as expected
white is starting to untangle here
trying to get these pieces back into
play
okay supposedly all the games are
underway
i can't find any of the players in a
game
search
okay so
i
i'm gonna do some work there
see what i can find
okay yeah supposedly yes
this is uh this is happening
i'm seeing the games now um so we're
kind of missing the first round then i
don't know
what exactly is going on
we get the second round
i don't know they're playing in live on
chess.com yeah
so apparently the games are underway
they're they're all somewhere they're
all
somewhere
yeah okay it looks like for edward jones
fishers of men actually did manage to
win both of his games
so i'm gonna go over here and look for
their board too see if he's still
playing
okay looks like paul frowan should still
be playing so i'm going to close this
game
and we're going to go over here
and okay paul is no longer playing
okay this is all very very strange very
very strange
okay i'm gonna put this over here see
what i can find
and nothing
absolutely nothing
well
i guess this serves us right
for
using this website
okay
let's see what i can do
i'm told that paul frowan is playing a
chess game right now
everybody agrees chess.com agrees
paul frowan playing a chess game where
is he
where is he at
oh boy
okay anybody
anybody
pendulum
moneyballin where where are any of these
people
big daddy jazz come on all right
i don't have the answers everybody i
don't have the answers
all right all right check this out
everybody maybe we can switch to more of
a full screen ben yeah all right check
this out paul frowan look look at this
guy corporate chess league diamond
member he's playing right now so here's
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna click this
button
and and here we are
and
here we are
where where where are you at paul where
did he go
i don't know i don't have the answers
what did that little message just say
there um it just said another login has
been detected because i logged in on on
two spots
well this is really unfortunate
this is yeah wildly unfortunate i don't
i'm not
not certain
i wonder why that one game worked though
yeah just we we got one game that's all
we deserved
okay
well let me know if you want to take a
break
yeah maybe we'll take a quick break
we'll come back for round two and
hopefully we can see more chess games so
sorry about the technical difficulties
everybody um stay tuned with us we'll be
right back hopefully with with all the
chess
[Music]
yo yo yo yo back in
st louis at the st louis chess club yes
sir i want to talk about presentation
presenting chess
presenting chess over the years i mean
it has evolved it has changed so much
you know nowadays we got everything
we got computers right we've got
all the cameras that are showing players
from multiple angles internet video
it's like audio i can't even imagine if
i was able to sit and watch yesterday
and the us chess championship had video
of that to be able to watch it live
instantly no back in the day
they had the
the kids in the russian i remember you
know they showed us in the queen's
gambit they're
actually hooking chess pieces and
putting them on these giant boards
that's right for people to follow right
but the real original i think great
great presentation for chess
was shelby lyman calling fisher spassky
pbs on pbs tell us about it well first
of all it was like from russia with love
the james bond movie
where you know the the evil character is
playing chess and you're right it's it
it's the
moving of the pieces on the stick and
there's no commentary it's just like
everybody whispering oh my gosh that's a
good move you know
they got their sets
shelby live and
revolutionized
chess in america chess on tv
and it was hilarious because now we
watch it we go oh my god that's terrible
uh the guy would say stop what we're
doing he's not the the telefax machinist
it's spitting out a move and everybody
run to the machine and go oh my god
shelby had pieces in his pocket he
forgot to put back on the board it was
amateur hour and america loved it they
had never
chess was greek
jesus is greek and here's a guy
talking about
how important the pawn was
you can't lose that bud if you lose the
pawn maurice you're going to lose
influence over here and this was at the
time when fischer was playing against
basketball exactly the cold war era yeah
maverick american against the soviet
dominance and he played into that as
well as the whole fever of chess in
america
was ready for that kind of commentary
front page news it was amazing no i mean
it's ridiculous walter cronkite
the voice of american news he would
start his presentation about the great
stories of the day boom boom boom boom
boom but before we get into those
stories
bobby fischer is leasing his matching
his boys
he's number three and we're going to go
into reykjavik and get an update amazing
it was like what
this is fantastic and as a result of
that of course a slew of grandmasters
came along yourself and benjamin is the
bobby and the generation but we jump
ahead and we go to
my first time doing commentary i'm in
the kremlin in moscow the first sporting
event ever held in the kremlin who does
a sporting event in this political
institution right but the intel world
chess grand prix gets a sponsorship
kasparov is able to get that pull as the
world champion and we're in the kremlin
i'm there for eurosport
with danny
this is before danny king and i actually
tape and we're sitting there bob rice
who's the president of the
professional chess association
he says to me maurice the russians are
doing commentary we americans we can't
understand anything would you mind going
up in a booth and just
talking and explaining the games just so
that we can follow kasparov and kramnik
on stage for the foreign foreign
visitors so i go up they hook me up in
this old school
booth i'm like what's going on i'm by
myself i got on the headset i got the
microphone i'm looking down on the stage
and gary's playing crom nick and i
decide i'm not doing commentary like old
school commentaries
i'm gonna do it like john madden and
mark albert
like like it's pro sports right so i'm
shouting at the top of my lungs by
myself in the room
and i'm going oh my god
did you see what he missed this is
unbelievable right i hear that clara
kasparova later the mother
mother she can't speak any english but
the sound coming from my voice
through everybody else's headset
earpiece that they're listening in on
was so dynamic and interesting that she
changed from russian to
just to listen to me modulating up and
down so she could be excited about the
game just the drama of it fantastic
that's how i started that's fanta that's
a fantastic story nothing similar but
there's something i love there was a
match between
um
deep fritz
and vladimir kramnik in bonn germany
and you know
germany
so they had german commentators a whole
group of them
and the germans thought well
okay we're going to have one english
commentary one english we have like r2
yusuf klaus bishop uh helmuth lager all
of these germans all lined up and there
was me like you in the one booth
so i did my commentary and unfortunately
for vladimir he lost to the computer the
d that was the checkmate in one yeah
i go down the escalator
and this german man with the heaviest
german accent says mr
chervan uh
thank you thank you uh
i i
change
digit
i listen you
english very good english
schwein nietzsche
[Laughter]
and i got
the the bottom line is people
were not only interested in the chess
but they were also interested in how you
present the english and the english
words a lot of kids have come up to me
and said
i learned how to pronounce naidor or
anpris
or fianchetto
the enchanto from you and i was like
what
i'm the worst the bass
what you would think
and you know you talk about that even in
this digital age where now we have all
these presentations in fancy ways and
cameras and multiple angles you still
get characters you taught me about a
character
a commentator who has this distinctive
voice oh my gosh
the way he presents sharjah please tell
us that was terrible terrible terrible
so sharjah in the united arab emirates
was hosting
the world blitz
championships the world rapid
championships and they poured all their
money all their resources
into the playing hall the prize fund the
hotels the ambiance and somebody said
oh my gosh we're going to
show the games live
you know just the moves but maybe we
should get a commentator
so there was a grand master in residence
at the charizard chess club and it's
sort of like
we he didn't even know it but he was put
there
well i've got to tell you something
i mean i'll he'll go nameless but i just
have to say he was the worst commentator
i've ever heard my life and he would be
talking like this
oh you see mob news smog news look how
he played
two bishops so nice oh my god what'd he
do he gave him two bishops why
madness he know he understands
i was like you bet you better come over
here this was great we were laughing
the guy became a cult figure
because he was just so awful
well let's get started okay let's do
commentary yeah you're playing a
sicilian oh come on
that's right
you don't accept them
that's a sarah you should be ashamed of
yourself
boring chest i can't believe this we got
to go into morocco
oh my god i can't believe look at this
guy this is the guy i'm just gonna
cackle
[Music]
my name is alex kirford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and team captain
of our ever jones test team
[Music]
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity for companies around the st
louis area and hopefully one day beyond
to come and compete at a
world-class facility of chess that we
have here in st louis and we decided to
get a tournament around that to where
companies can play one another compete
in a friendly
a competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well
chess is important for
a wide variety of people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving being able to think long term
and have short term intermediate steps
can
translate into all types of different
areas of life
ever jones chose to
compete in the corporate chess league as
a way that we can
have some fun camaraderie with other
companies that we're associated with as
well as a way to
for ourselves be able to build some some
teamwork aspects as we have as a company
and again just be able to kind of
participate at a top class facility and
have some fun
[Music]
yo man what's up what's up listen we're
here in front of the saint louis chess
club
and uh it's the world famous club as you
know we live here all the time but there
are great clubs all around the world
absolutely and uh i gotta say there's a
great clubs in new york city
yeah for sure i just played on a lot of
them you got to talk new york city the
marshall chess club i was champion of
the marshall chester though let me just
humble no right
absolutely
you know that club was pretty strong and
somehow i managed to win a championship
there
but
the importance of clubs
for chess especially now
in the digital age
yeah in the past that you couldn't
overstate the importance of the club the
club
was the place it's the hub man that's
where everybody went that's where we
talked to each other do you know about
the russian championships you got the
bulletins we traded books we traded
stories we analyzed we played so the
clubs
especially in the 70s 80s 90s man that
was the gathering place and in
on the west coast we had a marvelous
club the mechanics chess club san
francisco i've been there did lectures
played there
and
that club from the 1850s
right still a vibrant place today that's
like a marvelous place in new york what
was your favorite hangout well you know
like you said without the clubs how do
you find players exactly i remember
going to the manhattan chess club the
manhattan chess club no longer exists
now
it was an institution in fact the
manhattan moved into the carnegie hall
building exactly like you know you were
on the 10th floor when you arrive
as a musician you go to carnegie hall of
course when you arrive at the chess
player you go to the manhattan chess
club exactly
i remember going into the manhattan club
and you you've got all these famous
grandmasters in there and we'd have
friday night blitz right and i would
have played in those two i would walk in
right and i remember once i walked into
the friday night blitz and
you know there was uh steve emmett the
tournament director and i said jeffrey
kastner no in particular i remember
steve inman when i walked in and i said
to steve who's playing in the blitz
tonight
and he says to me no he says to me you
can't ask who's playing in the blitz and
then not play he thought i was trying to
you know
get a fast one hustle right i said to
him
i only want to play if there's strong
players playing
and he's charging well we've got
benjamin we've got fed we got deluge
yesterday sign me up yeah i mean that's
the kind of strength level you had at
that club you always wanted to play so
it allowed me to get stronger as a
player if there were no clubs there was
no internet and stuff to to
be able to just jump on and get a strong
player anytime you want you needed a
club in order to make that happen no
question about it and for me
and seattle when i was growing up we had
the american chess service the acs and
we had a guy organizer there's always
one organizer who is you know like there
all the time robert anthony carts we
call him rack
and rack organized tournaments i am not
kidding nearly every weekend
congresses i remember playing in these
you know at any kind of holiday there
was a thanksgiving day tournament there
was a columbus day tournament there was
a
president's day open you know all of
these tournaments and that's where i got
strong that's where i cut my teeth and
you know sharpened my game and
where i actually met all my friends now
today you want to talk about a digital
age like ah
it's it's all online which has been good
in many ways but i miss this
the camaraderie at the club move you
know i'm thinking about i'm thinking
about old school clubs like the flea
house oh brilliant you know my my good
homeboy willie johnson
pop he's telling me about the days in
the fleet house where he's coming up he
see uh ginger josh really hanging out
and those players you know about the
fleet house oh gosh yes uh
okay i go there in 1977 i'm 17 years old
as strong as an og surfer swimmers build
long hair
afro actually here
come in
and the guy says to me you look like
you're looking for something what are
you looking for
say a chess game
social or for money
i play for a little money come with me
brings me to the table
guys guys holding court
got a new customer says the guy says
where you from i go seattle go seattle
that's close to alaska
alaska
gets night out
understand me
at that exact moment in my life
there was one possibly two people in the
entire united states who could play even
with me they were walter brown and
bernard zuckerman and that was it
everybody else if i don't recognize
bernard zuckerman or walter brown you're
toast
hello and welcome back to round two of
the corporate chess league uh we're
still experiencing some technical
difficulties here but if there's one man
who can see us through it it's gonna be
mega cake we're here we're watching mega
cake men
and uh i would love to be able to show
you guys some of these other games for
example i'm gonna pull up fisher's men
here
and i'm gonna see if we can watch his
game
um but nope it's just mega cake it's
making cake all the way down
maybe
maybe
maybe we can go to paul frowand
and watch paul's game i'd love to watch
paul's game
and no it's still mega kick all right
maybe
maybe debo maybe debo is the hero for us
although no he's not he's not playing
yet so we'll
we'll give him time
uh maybe maybe deseret can we watch
deseret play eli let's see
still still gonna be mega cake there
unfortunately
all right last but not least i love
legos too he's playing a game let's
check it out
and okay looks like we're in for mega
cake okay love mega cake we'll we'll
switch back over to this one
and uh stick with mega cake here he's up
against oak ave should be a fun game
so we'll take a look here
um so far so good for for the cake man
uh he's got the big center uh central
pawn duo let's see how we ended up here
so we had uh this is a pretty common
mistake by beginners usually you want to
be able to recapture on d5 with a pawn
it's super important that black gets
some kind of claim in the center whereas
after this move
white is going to be able to take over
eventually with e4
as you see here
now i actually don't love how make a
cake handle this because black actually
has a really interesting move here of e5
which um can be a pretty interesting
pawn sacrifice i think this is actually
equalizing for black with best play so
it could have been an interesting way
for oak ave to get back that claim in
the center but he played e6 instead and
now white's just going to be
actually more than a little bit better
with this central pawn duvo should be
very very nice for white you have all
this extra space and that's going to
lead to problems for black like not
being able to develop this bishop
you can imagine if this pawn was on e5
especially would be able to come out to
e6 maybe g4 with this pawn on e6 not so
easy to find a square for this bishop
um
so yeah we'll stick with mega cake here
this is this is who we've got this is
who we've got playing
um and i'll keep you apprised of the
results otherwise i can actually tell
you how we finished up in round one
there i think we went to the break
before we knew
uh but enterprise did end up being dardy
although it was a competitive match uh
so enterprise walked away with that the
20 grand pre points for that match and
then in a reasonably big upset we saw
ascension actually tying the match with
edward jones so they both will get 10
grand pre points and this has been
happening a little bit more often than
normal for edward jones they've been
giving up these uh these these match
draws more often than than you might
expect
so
look out look out this season ascension
very competitive team might be looking
to take home their first first gold
okay in the meantime uh we saw white
breaking in the center here with d5 and
i think we're about to see disaster for
oak ave he seems to be falling for a bit
of a trap here don't think you can take
this guy back bishop takes h7 and oh and
we're going to see it played we're going
to see it played this is a uh this is an
important one to to know
whenever you have uh this is actually a
super common tactic whenever you have
things opening up in the center it looks
like this queen might not be defending
the pawn because the bishop is in the
way but more often than not this bishop
can move out of the way with check and
that
is a discovered attack it discovers the
queen attacking on d5 reveals this
threat and make a cake already up a
queen against oak ave
uh maybe someday we'll we will see a
second game but i i i'm guessing before
we're able to watch anything we're gonna
have to get through round two of mega
cake here
um i am gonna try something i'm gonna
try one more thing i'm gonna see if i
can just unfollow everybody i don't want
to follow anybody anymore i'm done
following people i'm going to close this
game
go back over here
i'm going to go back to fishers of men
i'm going to click this one more time
and yeah i just can't i see nothing i
see nothing
players can i can i see fishers of men
no he's not my friend is he a top player
is he is he fishers
fishers of
men anybody oh there he is okay okay
he's online something he's playing can i
can i watch
i can't watch i i i just i can't do it i
can't do it
i'm sorry i wish i could do it
but i can't
um let me
let me pull up make a cake again let's
stick with that one let's stick with
what works
stick with what works here
yeah he there he is true
uh make a cake is true he would never uh
he would never abandon us
okay so knight g5 that's a mate threat
bishop f5 that's going to stop the mate
threat there you saw check knight g5
bishop f5 good enough to defend bishop
back to g6 that's a tempo move
and it looks like it's a queen for a
bishop here uh so
you know one for one one piece for one
should be
still competitive but we'll see
we'll see what we've got going on
[Music]
yeah and maybe make a cake can get this
last candidate spot that just opened up
maybe we can petition fide um say hey i
know 1900 not not quite up to up to par
with the rest of the candidates
competitors but
he is literally the only game you can
watch on chess.com right now so i think
that counts for a lot because otherwise
just nobody's going to be able to
spectate the candidates so if you don't
have mega cake there
how how is anybody going to see the
candidates
so queen h4
um still eyeing up these these h7
squares maybe uh maybe okav can try and
pose some problems something like bishop
e7 at least put him into a nasty little
bit of a pin
but obviously you know a queen is a
queen a bishop is a bishop you'd rather
have the queen
like i said whenever you're down
material like this you're just looking
to to cause problems you know if you can
make like a single
serious threat a serious problem for
your opponent then uh then you're doing
well and that's really what it's all
about here it's not about trying to win
by force anymore it's about finding some
way to give your opponent just these
annoying little problems and if you can
do that for five and a half minutes then
you win on time that's how i handle
these things at least that's how i
handle these things
um so okaff is probably just looking for
ways to to try and poke and prod at his
opponent that's that's what you got to
do here you don't have to win by force
because you can't win by force you just
have to be annoying be annoying for as
long as you can
and then you might
live to see the end of the game
so white is actually making a threat by
the way we have this queen moving
sideways attacking this bishop on b4 so
i want to move it back to e7 of course
the bishop is defended by the knight but
white can capture this and then capture
on b4 winning some more material
okay the worst has happened uh which is
97 just undefending the bishop willingly
now however queen's moving sideways not
an easy chess rule to to keep in mind
okay but make a cake super strong gonna
notice the queen's moving sideways
that's more than i can say for myself in
some of my recent tournament games i i
have in fact missed queens moving
sideways before
carlson once the match with ferrugia
little did he know no one's going to see
it unless it's make a cake so change
change your expectations buddy
be realistic all right queen c4 c6
defends the knight
good enough
um it is now just queen for nothing
which is going to make life a little bit
harder but again
mega cake we've seen some connection
issues from him we've seen some
connection issues maybe
maybe he's going to be able to uh or
maybe oak ave is going to be able to put
some pressure on the clock
homeless on wifi says d4 d5 was a cheapo
e4e5 would have been better for winning
a piece or a mating attack
um
yeah i i don't know if i entirely agree
maybe i do agree
maybe i do agree e5 here does look
pretty difficult to deal with and i
think what he's uh mentioning is that
bishop takes h7 might be a winning
threat if uh if you move the piece away
i'm just sort of wondering if i can play
knight g4 in that position i think
knight g4 might be saving saving my skin
although for how long i don't know yeah
i think e4 e5 would have been a great
move d4 d5 to be honest with you is is
probably also uh quite strong here i
think white is is winning regardless
i'm gonna cheat let's see what the the
engine thinks yeah it thinks e5 plus
four
d5 only like plus one
yeah no good
no good should have gone e5
but the cheapo worked out
and now 96 the the rook falls we get a
check
this game is is looking rough this game
is looking rough
okay rookie one check now
and yeah what to do at this point you're
up so much material you can even just
start giving some of it back play like
rook cd one where it takes d5 and just
checkmate this
king bishop f7 you might play rookie
seven just to
really
really get him
not much left to do with with black here
no problems left to pose
so i think four minutes will be plenty
now for mega cake to get the job done
and yeah if magnus declines the mega
cake match then i guess we'll have a new
world champion as manny many points out
okay rick takes d5 here seems simple
enough you just rip open the the
remaining shelter around the king and
checkmate will be will be coming
okay queen h4
yeah this is something that that you
might might be useful to uh to take away
from
whenever you're up this much material
you you sure you can keep everything but
don't be afraid to give some of it back
like rook takes c5 makes your life so
much easier uh it's like checkmate in a
few and you're really not risking
anything by giving up the rook for the
night here like you're just not risking
anything you're up enough
so that might make your life a little
bit simpler if you're more willing to
give some of the material back uh in
this case though of course everything is
going to be winning
because white is up a billion pieces so
now i want to play rook e7 give up in
exchange this way because it's checkmate
in a few
okay and megacake does see this one
that is gonna be good enough so if the
king goes to the back row we'll go queen
h8 the bishop defends the rook and if
the knight takes we'll play queen takes
and then uh rook d8 mate so queen h8
here
it's going to be checkmate in two
jake mate as they say
okay rook takes a seven check also legal
also very a very legal way to play chess
okay still queen 88 is mate okay he sees
it now he sees it now
and then bishop e8 takes on e8 this game
is over another one in the books for
make a cake as expected
continuing on round two
once again mega cake always there for us
even when no one else is
move to a3 look at this guy look at oak
have
playing like richard rapport
uh kind of not really
uh in one of richard rapport's recent
games uh let me see if i can draw some
arrows here
we had a pretty interesting opening that
went d4 d5 c4 e6
knight c3
a6
a3
uh some sort of super gm battle of who
can waste the most time in the opening
interesting stuff i don't fully
understand why they do it i also don't
fully understand why a3 was played here
looks like okav is going for a quick b4
b5 and i don't know why but i respect it
he's going for it
can someone help me how do i unfollow
this channel um i'll tell you how to
unfollow our channel if you tell me how
to follow a chess.com player because
it's just it can't be done
can't be done
okay wait to move here um again we just
need to get our pieces developed i would
have liked to see white develop the
pieces before playing b4 b5 because once
again
you want to get your pieces in the game
you want to get your king castle before
you try to open things up it might seem
like it's more useful to open things up
do these pawn pushes rather than quote
unquote waste time developing your
pieces
but it turns out that your position is
just going to be so much better you're
going to be so much more prepared for
the opening up of things if you castle
first and we're seeing sort of the
ramifications of that here queen to a5
and it's gonna get a little bit awkward
for white uh you have to play queen to
d2 to defend this knight and i think the
awkward move bishop b4 is going to be
just directly winning the game here for
black taking advantage of the newly
found pin along the a file adding a
second attacker to this knight and
white's not going to be able to defend
whereas if this pawn was still on b2
this move would not cause any problems
at all for white
so that'll show you
that will show you how to uh how to
punish
your opponents for opening things up too
quickly
so again i know everybody knows this but
castle your king develop your pieces
control the center and then
try to play for these middle game ideas
these minority attack ideas
but
you have to uh to take care of business
first
d2 best move king d2 i think is going to
lose to 94 shaq i think probably queen
to d2 is is actually the best move and
then after bishop b4 you just have to
take it lose your rook over here and
just uh be an exchange down um
but it's it's very sad it's a very sad
story
queen d2 though probably the best you
can do alternatively you can play knight
d2 here give up the piece play like
bishop e2 or something but i think it's
better just to give
just to give the exchange
okay bishop e2 played instead um i guess
probably king f1 is what white's gonna
do after queen c3
and
okay knight d2 instead also fine this
kind of transposes
now black might take this guy
black might take this guy yeah black
might go here preventing castles
uh probably now we need to play
something like f3 just you need to sort
out this the situation around our king
but down a full piece uh okav is going
to have some trouble going to have some
trouble here
bishop d3 is is pretty similar
black can do any number of things he
does just choose to take on d2 making
making things a little bit simpler um oh
i missed uh missed at the rook hanks on
a1 my bad
yep this is
super winning
super winning now
okay king back to e2 but it's it's not
really going to matter here and again
uh
500 ways to win here with uh
with black any legal move
probably wins the game unless you hang
your queen for nothing in which case you
might still win
uh okay bishop d6 again i like this from
mega kick you just want to simplify
things a little bit make your position
unlosable however maybe there was a
tactic with rook to b3
maybe there's a little bit of a tactic
there could have undefended the the
bishop uh i think black does have queen
a6 check though to uh step out of the
out of the threat
okay bishop g5 maybe now knight e4
attacks a lot of things at the same time
and white might lose
yet another piece unfortunately the
pieces are falling mega cake remains
dominant in the corporate chess league
today
i kind of wonder who make a cake is
because
if they were on one of the teams they
would um they would be playing in the
main matches
so i think this might be a house player
from from the chess club here although
i'm not sure which one not sure who it
could be
oh queen to d1 oh no
oh no naked cake's gonna spot that one i
think
make a cake's gonna spot that one
no good
no good
yeah knight c3 check comes
and the queen is gone
sad times
sad times in the corporate chess league
rook b8 now
checkmate is near
white's pieces are dwindling
okay rook to d7
and
any number of moves lead to mate here
rook b1 check makes a lot of sense queen
a1 check also makes sense
um
let's see let's calculate to mate yeah
rook b1 king e2 now this king is going
to try to run out to f3
so maybe you even just play like e5 e4
to stop it okay queen c1 threatens mate
in one so you have to play oh there is
there is nothing to play if king f3 then
uh queen d1 is mate
and yeah queen d1 checkmate is played
thus ends the matches of mega cake for
the evening
i am
gonna make an attempt here to see if we
can watch any of these games
um nope still getting mega cake there
um
see if i can refresh this
okay desrat's offline now looks like his
games are done for the day
all right we're gonna try one more time
to pull some games up here so i'm gonna
go to a quick break and see if we can
get these games pulled up
so
[Music]
yo man what's up what's up listen we're
here in front of the st louis chess club
and uh it's the world famous club as you
know we live here all the time but there
are great clubs all around the world
absolutely and uh i gotta say there's a
great clubs in new york city
yeah for sure i just played on a lot of
them you got to talk new york city the
marshall chess club i was champion of
the marshall chestnut let me just humble
you all right absolutely
uh you know that club was pretty strong
and somehow i managed to win a
championship there
but
the importance of clubs
for chess especially now
in the digital age yeah in the past you
couldn't overstate the importance of the
club the club
was the place it's the hub man that's
where everybody went that's where we
talked to each other do you know about
the russian championships you got the
bulletin we traded books we traded
stories we analyzed we played so the
clubs
especially in the 70s 80s 90s man that
was the gathering place
and in
on the west coast we have a marvelous
club the mechanics chess club san
francisco i've been there did lectures
played there
and
that club from the 1850s
right still a vibrant place today that's
like a marvelous place in new york what
was your favorite hangout well you know
like you said without the clubs how do
you find players exactly i remember
going to the manhattan chess club the
manhattan chess club no longer exists
now but it was an institution in fact
the manhattan moved into the carnegie
hall building exactly like you know
you're up on the 10th when you arrive
as a musician you go to carnegie hall of
course when you arrive at the chess
player you go to the manhattan chess
club exactly
i remember going into the manhattan club
and you you've got all these famous
grand masters in there and we'd have
friday night blitz right and i would
have played in those two i would walk in
right and i remember once i walked into
the friday night blitz and you know
there was uh steve emmett the tournament
director and i sent you jeffrey kastner
no in particular i remember steve inman
when i walked in and i said to steve
who's playing in the blitz tonight
and he says to me no he says to me you
can't ask who's playing in the blitz and
then not play he thought i was trying
you know
get a fast one hustle right i said to
him
i only want to play if there's strong
players playing
and he's charging well we've got
benjamin we've got fed we got dulu
yesterday signed me up i'm in that's the
kind of strength level you had at that
club you always wanted to play so it
allowed me to get stronger as a player
if there were no clubs there was no
internet and stuff to to
be able to just jump on and get a strong
player anytime you want you needed a
club in order to make that happen no
question about it and for me
and seattle when i was growing up we had
the american chess service the acs and
we had a guy organizer there's always
one organizer who is you know like there
all the time robert anthony carts we
called him rack
and rack organized tournaments i am not
kidding nearly every week
okay hello everyone and welcome back to
the corporate dress league spring season
uh difficult night here tonight for us
not gonna lie to you but uh i am coming
back to let you know some of these final
scores as they're coming in here
so mega cake
undefeated on the night and we have
learned the secret identity of mega cake
he is uh one of the tournament directors
for the corporate chess league filling
in here as a player
um and in the actual matches tonight
let's just recap what we've had going on
we've had enterprise defeating dougherty
in the first round we've had edward
jones tying their match against
ascension so enterprise gets 20 grand
pre-points for that win edward jones and
ascension both walking away with 10
grand pre-points plus the scores they
got in the actual matches
and then over here in round two uh
edward jones has officially defeated
doherty um
so they also will be getting 20 grand
prix points for that performance and
then the match against ascension and
enterprise is actually still up in the
air here they had
enterprise had a one point lead leading
into this uh final round i think and now
we're waiting on the results between s
gilmore 999 who is still playing as you
might be able to see on your screen
uh and we're also waiting for for the
result from maurice gp so let me see if
i can pull up his profile as well
gp
uh whose second game is actually over
maurice won his second game so that
actually
i believe levels the match score between
ascension and enterprise so it all comes
down to this final game between s
gilmore 999 against big daddy jazz for
enterprise whoever wins this game will
secure match victory
for their team
um absolutely wild stuff now you know
what i would love is if i could click on
this button
and we could see that game
but that's not an option for us here
today unfortunately that's not going to
happen so what we're going to do instead
we're going to hang out a little bit and
i'm going to click refresh
every few minutes here
and we're going to see if we can get a
result because you guys deserve to know
who wins this match between ascension
and enterprise
in the meantime maybe we can take a look
at this game that is already finished
here we'll take a look at this game
between gilmore and big daddy jazz see
if we can define who we think is going
to have the upper hand in the uh in the
rematch here looks like gilmore had
white started off with the queen's
gambit and early bishop f4
so far so good again an early a3 not
sure what all that's about maybe he was
worried about knight to b4 fair enough
okay we saw ooh knight h5 and this is
going to lead to some complications here
bishop h7 checks will look like gilmore
was winning a piece here right
looks like this should be an extra piece
for gilmore
with that inner meso then bishop f6
happened ooh knight takes d4 and this is
where things got a little bit more
complex
then bam take on e5 take on e5 and big
daddy jazz not going for the tempting
knight b3 seeing that the that white
could trade the queens and not lose any
material so instead we get c6 and rook
over to d1 now causes some problems so
pawn to c5
takes rook b8 okay
right he gets unpinned and he punishes
white for not getting castled with the
queen e5 check and then ooh queen to e3
big miss by uh gilmore there that's the
queen loser
then bam rook b2 the knight falls as
well and just resigns gilmore just gives
it up the bishop falls next then this is
just gonna be checkmate oh my goodness
what a dominating performance by big
daddy jazz however
i will point out that uh s gilmore
stephen gilmore is the big favorite for
this final match here in raiding so
we'll see if gilmore can get it done if
gilmore does win this game i believe
that secures match victory for ascension
if there is a draw ascension will walk
away with two tied matches here tonight
kind of a wild result and if big daddy
jazz can win then that secures match
victory for enterprise i think this
could be uh this could be a big upset
so with that analyzed let's refresh this
one more time
okay the game's still underway god only
knows what's happening though i can only
guess i can only guess maybe if i click
follow something good will happen i'm
following him okay
good to know
good to know i'm going to unfollow him
now
and i'm going to click the spectate
button
and
there's desrat now i'm following desuret
somebody new
okay
that was unexpected um however that's
not the person i wanted to follow
um
very very strange how all these accounts
seem to now sudden suddenly be connected
through mysterious circumstances all
right i've unfollowed everybody
let's try this one more time
s gilmore
still does rat still
still deseret i don't
i don't understand
okay
no longer following anyone i'm gonna
click the x on that game get this game
out of my face i don't want that game
anymore i'm gonna go back to s gilmore i
want to watch him
nobody just there's nobody
okay well
we are at the mercy of uh of stephen
gilmore here we will wait
we will stick with it we will find out
the result of this game
and i will i will click on it once this
result shows up and we will we will
analyze it
um so let's see if we can check in here
see what kind of scores we've got so
yeah edward jones had a pretty good
night they are gonna end up with let's
see they got 14 points from round one
and they got 25 points from round two
that's 39 points on the night for edward
jones they're the big winners so far i
think
enterprise gets 25 points from round one
and at least
two and a half points from round two
depending on this final result here it's
either going to be
two and a half 12 and a half or 22 and a
half depending on this one single game
they've got everything to play for here
in this final match
ascension meanwhile has already picked
up uh 14 points as well waiting for
their second round result
and darty having a bit of a rough night
lost both their matches picked up a
point in each round though
um so they're not they're not walking
away with nothing
and then uh bayer is not playing this
round so
they scored the least
okay how long can this game possibly
take how can they still be playing
how can they still be playing
there must be some way for me to find
this game it's the last game underway i
just want to see it
i just want to see it chess.com how
difficult can it be what if i type it
over here s gilmore
so i tried to get into the s gilmore
game and it just took me back to mega
cake
all right ben is still watching mega
cake oh and we just got raided hello
everybody hello everybody we're in a
unique situation here uh thank you sandy
rose chess for the raid um this is the
corporate chess league here in st louis
what is the corporate chess league it is
a league for corporations in the st
louis area to compete with each other
see who has the best chess players on
their team and we're having a little bit
of trouble with chess.com i'm not gonna
lie to you so there's one game remaining
and that is the game between s gilmore
999 up against big daddy jazz 64.
whoever wins this game wins the match
for their team
however
if i click on this watch button
nothing happens
nothing happens i'm not allowed not
allowed to see this game
so so we're really struggling so what
we're going to do we're going to hang
out it
cannot be much longer until this game
finishes i promise and we're gonna we're
gonna see the result of this game i am
gonna know who won this game before we
go away for the night
um we had maurice gp scoring one and a
half out of two for ascension that is
big news why don't we take a look at
this game since we've got some time how
did maurice score two full points on
board two for ascension
we had d4 d5 c4 e6 okay so far so normal
and we had another semi-slav player okay
take on c4 yeah so an early bishop d3 by
by white so take on c4 knight d5 is a
little strange but that's all okay
white does push through with e4 so
whenever this happens you see white with
this big central space advantage black
is going to have to fight back either
with e5 or c5 before too long otherwise
white's going to be able to take over
so we got castles bishop back to d3
and yeah
now c5 is played so great play by
maurice so far you can give up this
center just for a limited amount of time
but then you have to strike back this
time he does it with c5
okay rook to e1 b6 all good
uh brick to e8 yeah so far these guys
are playing like pros so e5 introduced
the threat on h7 that's why uh black was
ready with rookie 8 so that you can
defend this nice little move knight f8
not making any weaknesses yet bishop b4
but black is ready with rook b8 now
queen to a4 does hit this a7 pawn so
okay queen or pawn to a6
um but i'm a little bit curious yeah
bishop c6 looks dangerous but black was
ready with b5 and now bishop d7
and black is getting untangled okay we
see a d5 push but black's pieces are
springing to life now you can see 96
great idea by black blockading this pawn
and from behind this pawn this knight is
kind of a monster
looks like a great position for black
now pawn to c4 he's starting to take
over
um we see okay knight in but that's a
free queen
yeah unfortunate miss there queen g6
offered the queen trade knight c6 misses
it
and now the extra queen is enough for
more grease to just win the game
wow
tough end to the game there very tough
end to the game
um
unfortunate
all right how are we doing gilmore how
are we doing
still playing this game i'm gonna i'm
gonna click it again i'm ready i'm gonna
open it in an incognito window we're
gonna see what happens
nothing nothing i cannot watch it
incognito can i watch it in a new window
yeah i can't watch it in a new window
either
tough tough well
i mean how long how long can this last
game go how long can this game go
earn points for the raid you're off now
okay thank you everybody for joining
from the sandyrose chess chess raid
thank you thank you
um no games in progress wait a second
what does that mean
you would expect if they're playing
there would be a game in progress that's
what i would expect at least that's what
i would expect
okay in the meantime let's just keep
analyzing let's just keep analyzing
let's go on to board one of ascension
here we've got frank t tan
uh who managed to split his games
against
kendalum who's playing for enterprise
let's check out the win let's check out
his win
okay it looks like more blunders in this
game but we'll take a look at it
started off with a scandy oh my goodness
frank a scandi player
um so far seems pretty normal black
activates the queen a little bit early
on in this opening and it looks like
some pressure against b2
white wasn't worried about it though
black gets a little bit more developed
and then does actually capture here
yes so this bishop e3 move maybe not
ideal black now by taking is attacking
this knight on c3 so there's not as much
risk of like rook b1 being a problem
so knight to b5 was played for that
reason um now knight to a6 rook b1 but
queen a2 is there
okay rick back to a1
now queen comes out to d5
oh and rook takes a6 look at this
sacrifice ready with knight to c7
jumping in so what happened here okay
just queen back to d8
and then a6 and all right looks like
then things did go well for white in the
opening but black got developed had a
couple pawns for the piece
and then after takes takes saw takes
takes
bishop takes on f1 okay so white lost
some material back there pawn to g7
rookie eight okay some wild stuff queen
to d6
to d8 oh and then the pin then the check
and then white undefends the rook on a1
and bam
frank
wins this one frank wins this one
okay all right well
how you doing stephen how you doing
oh the game's over
he lost he lost the game we got to see
how it happened we got to see how it
happened so with that
big daddy jazz
wins the match for doherty by a half
point just winning by a hair in the end
um actually a full point but kind of a
half point based on the match situation
um how did it happen how did gilmore
end up losing it here he was the rating
favorite he just needed to score a half
point to tie the match
um the game started off reasonably
normal it looks like and then
wow gilmore advancing on the queen side
looks pretty interesting it goes a5 oh
but loses the exchange early on
okay b3 looks kind of weird this is a
pretty bad bishop there on a2
the knight comes into b6 now then over
to d5 gets rid of the bishop the e5 pawn
falls looks like domination from big
daddy jazz so far i'm going to be honest
ooh but then what's this knight c3
knight e3 and black it's the bishop i
even wonder if we could be be more
severe play something really crazy like
knight to f4 and the point is everything
is on this g2 pawn but knight c3 is good
enough to win a piece oh but then it
loses the knight on e7
so maybe not good enough in the end
okay we see a little bit of back and
forth here big daddy jazz playing some
good defensive chess defending on g2
the queens come off the board don't love
the queen trade here by um
by gilmore he and maybe he just
blundered that this was check but with
the queens off the board
now the extra material is going to be
very telling
and yeah up two exchanges now
and just sacrifices one pack but then
loses the rook
no loses the rook to an exchange
but then
loses on time i guess he must have lost
on time here oh my goodness came down to
a time scramble big daddy jazz lost his
remaining pieces but one on time
absolutely
a thrilling game i only wish we could
have seen it happen live but the the
game review almost is good
okay with that enterprise does secure
their second match victory they walk
away the big winners tonight winning
both of their matches
fun stuff huge shout out to uh mega cake
the only player i'm capable of following
um hopefully you guys enjoyed i know
there were a lot of technical
difficulties but i had fun with it
tonight hopefully you did as well um be
sure to tune in um not next thursday but
thursday after for the next round of
corporate chess and uh i will see you
next time thank you all so much for
joining have a good night
you